there's an awful lot to talk about today
a first ofit kind Summit to deal with
the rapid rise of car thefts a lowrisk
high-reward criminal Enterprise fueled
by new technologies that criminals are
using to defeat high-tech anti- theft
devices in modern vehicles in a lot of
cases these vehicles are selling for
double the retail value if they were
sold here in Canada Federal ministers
use the summit to boast about what
Ottawa has already done outlawing for
example some of the gadget criminals use
to break into cars or giving Ontario
$121 million to fight the problem and
boosting the budget of the Canada Border
Services Agency by $28 million and more
funding might be on the way we'll have
something to say and I mentioned this to
my friend commissioner DM something to
say about increased investments in the
RCMP and their policing Partners the
Trudeau government has boosted the
maximum sentence for car theft from 18
months to 2 years but but observers said
that extra 6 months it's not any
deterrent the criminal code needs to be
strengthened so that there are real
consequences for vehicle thieves we need
to see stiffer penalties we need to stop
these criminals and the Prime Minister
himself hinted his government would act
on that we're also looking at further
strengthening penalties for anyone who
participates in auto theft while his
ministers talk tough to organize crime
we say time's up Justin Trudeau is not
worth the crime Federal politicians also
use the Forum to take veiled shots at an
opposition leader Pierre POV who is
clearly getting under their skin we're
convening this Summit because Canadians
need serious action a catchy slogan
won't stop auto theft with lines like
this secure our
ports and lock up the car thieves the
summit also heard that one of the most
important things that can be done is to
share police intelligence with nonp
police actors that would be shipping
companies ways Port operators and so on
that kind of collaboration the experts
said is vital to stopping car theft
Rings Donna okay David aen thank you